let's read this tmg studios review
there's a tmg studios apparently in
maryland oh yes um that's somebody found
on google here it is right here um
that's uh
printer no that's us that's us we're in
maryland
[Music]
yes and the trick the whole time that's
the beam up to the ship it's in maryland
so that's why sometimes i don't know why
the [ __ ] we put it there it's a dumb
idea yeah we're gonna say that's why
sometimes that's why sometimes we're
late you know that's why i'm always late
yeah because we're taking some shitty
flight to maryland love my experience
here at tmg studios this way this is a
review that somebody left on google uh
it's clear to me that the workers here
love their jobs and know how to create a
comfortable environment one of the
workers not sure what his name was but i
remember his racial ambiguity it's quite
large in stature i recall him giving me
workout advice yeah yeah what can i say
he told me that he started to eat
protein bars with the rappers uh no w
and that's
what made the difference i love that guy
and his buddy too i can't forget him i
definitely will be back
imagining the employees of this company
be like what the [ __ ] are they talking
about what are they talking about who
are they talking about yo who here told
someone to eat the rapper five stars
though it's a
it's a commercial printer
man i was uh i went down a rabbit hole
of indiana geography i i can't what a
[ __ ] town this is so first of all i
went go-karting in a place called
whiteland but i was laughing at white
land and there's a just down the way
there's a new white land so then at that
show that night i
i talked to some person in the audience
i'm like where are you from he's like oh
i'm from brownsburg
and then i asked his buddy are you from
brownsburg too and i like i was debating
posting this clip but he goes not from
purplesville bro he goes i am but i
actually just moved to white's town i'm
like okay
and then some
and i'm like what the [ __ ] is going on
with your estate and then some kid
messages me after the show is like you
think that's bad he sends me a link to a
town called hindustan oh wow then i
started going around indiana and zach
you have some [ __ ] explaining to do
there's a russiaville there's a mexico
there's a denver a peru a new london
shanghai what
like shanghai shanghai indiana
russiaville yeah so somebody's just
[ __ ] around no they have the whole uh
there's a did i say this was a mexico
they put the whole globe in their one
area this i was just gas city
gas city [ __ ] gas gas city [ __ ]
is that what that is
oh yeah cool dunkirk albany portland
vermont hello everybody my name
is jeff
that's the best one jeff
jeff indiana what's the name of your
[ __ ] randolph
stone that's not bad i'm from jeff
you're a joke that's a joke get in there
rural indiana that's that's a i swear
i've heard this before i'm from rural
indiana no the town rural did you hear
what i just said no what
i'm from jeff
come on
my state is jeff
my place is jeff so stupid get the [ __ ]
out is that kyle ballstown
let's go
kyle dude it's just straight up kyle
which you know it's just below
manchester if you go down
kyle indiana i need the backstory on all
these places man
friendship the philippines i'm kidding
probably honestly yeah oh whoa um a
little saigon
this is correct
where are you from correct
no where are you from correct no i'm
asking you a question but you know
there's probably
there's probably a lot of
uh
you know towns like this seymour
you like that one
you like seymour
yes see more balls in your mouth oh
[ __ ] are you gonna say see more butts oh
this is buddha i don't think is this
still indiana it's kind of west this
cruising through the arctic it's just
making fun of me i just what the [ __ ]
like i need to know how all this was
named ireland now is this the case like
with every state i mean maybe if we
zoomed into another i feel like other
midwest states you know they have like
indigenous names for towns there's
probably dumbass cities around but you
know indiana is a special kind of stupid
brazil brazil indian brazil that's what
people mean when they say come to brazil
people don't mean brazil like the
country they mean brazil indiana
hey man come on down to brazil
you live in brazil right right above
correct it's right next to ballstown
we're just below shanghai yeah come to
my name jeff egypt
sick dude nice hit it again now do it
again morocco oh take me to beaver city
that's where i want to be yeah beaver
[Applause]
is there just so much land that you can
buy a chunk and just call it whatever
booby town
zach just messaged that they're the
former like mayor of fort wayne indiana
is named or was named harry balls
dude indiana [ __ ] rule we need to
move there man i gotta move there we
need to move there yeah you know what
they got la summers did they yeah okay
hairy balls balls crazy man they got a
hicksville
come to jeff
come to jazz definitely better the
fourth time come to jail come to the
jets
if if you're from indiana you can
explain even one of these i would love
to know